I have some really interesting video to go
through with you guys today.
We are going to look at an interview that
Republican Kentucky Senator Rand Paul did
yesterday on Newsmax TV with host Greg Kelly.
And he really makes a complete fool of himself.
And there's something very interesting happening
with Rand Paul.
You might remember that Rand Paul kind of
became buddies with Donald Trump while Donald
Trump was president.
They would play golf and increasingly Rand
Paul would defend the things that Donald Trump
would say and do.
And the pattern tended to be, Trump would
say something completely wacky or crazy or
suggest or enact some completely harebrained
policy or executive order.
And Rand Paul would then appear on TV and
he would sort of put like a slightly less
crazy spin on it compared to Donald Trump.
And compare it to the way Trump was talking
about the issue.
Rand Paul would seem marginally more rational.
But what's going on now is that with Donald
Trump gone, Rand Paul is still saying equivalently
wacky things as to what he was saying before.
But without the even crazier Trump to compare
him to, he seems as out of his mind as he
has been for many, many years.
So let's take a look at some of these.
Rand Paul here says you can't impeach a president
who has left office, of course, ignoring the
fact that Donald Trump was impeached while
in office.
It's the trial that will start soon.
But the impeachment of Trump, remember, impeachment
happens in the House, did take place while
Donald Trump was president.
He had a vote on the floor and 45 Republicans
said, look, you can't really impeach somebody
who's already left office.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
So they've been repeating this one a lot.
It's wrong.
Trump was impeached while president.
But imagine that defense anywhere else.
The murder I committed.
Yeah, I did that when I was a manager of a
KFC.
I don't have that job anymore.
So anything I did while working at that job
doesn't count because I can't get fired from
there anymore.
I already don't work there.
What where else would that argument apply?
And of course, it's factually wrong since
Trump was impeached while he was president
of the United States.
Then Rand Paul tries to both sides the January
6th Trump riots by saying, listen, remember
when that guy shot Steve Scalise?
He was a Bernie supporter incited by health
care.
Now, what incited by health care means, I
don't know.
But let's listen to Rand Paul is to beat this.
And I think it's a terrible thing that they're
doing to the country.
The other thing is, is that even on the facts
of the matter, whether or not there was an
incitement to violence, I also mentioned in
that speech you showed on the floor that,
look, when I was at the ball field and Steve
Scalise was almost killed, four other staffers
were shot, including one of them that was
10 feet from me.
The guy who shot that shot up the ball field
and almost killed 20 of us was a Bernie Sanders
supporter.
And he had been incited by health care, incited
by incited by health care is not a phrase
you typically hear in the world.
But of course, Rand Paul here is either being
disingenuous or ignorant.
Bernie Sanders didn't incite anyone to shoot
anybody.
If the guy who shot Steve Scalise was a Bernie
supporter and he shot Steve Scalise, that's
very different than Trump at twelve forty
five on January 6th saying we're going down
to the Capitol and Rudy's saying we're going
to do trial by combat and on and on.
And then at 115 p.m., 30 minutes later, they
do it.
They do it because Trump said it and because
they thought they could steal the election.
For Trump, the analogy is so absurd, it's
not even coherent.
And we're seeing this from more Republicans
than just Rand Paul trying to sort of both
sides of this to try to make what happened
on January 6th equivalent to other things.
And of course, there's there's two layers
in which there's two ways in which it's not
equivalent.
Number one, the acts that took place on January
6th, they're dramatically different than what
these right wingers are trying to equate them
to.
But more importantly, no president sitting
or former incited any of the other stuff that
they are talking about.
And that's the subject matter of the impeachment.
Rand Paul then goes on a very strange rant
where he starts saying that a lot of what
is called climate change might merely be the
result of the Earth's tilt, not greenhouse
gases or human activities on Earth.
Scientists disagree with what Rand Paul is
saying here.
Remember, Rand Paul's an ophthalmologist.
Well, some of this started a while back because,
you know, when we started talking about climate
change and global warming, that was before
they decided they weren't sure whether it
was getting colder or warmer.
But now it's climate change.
It's become so sort of settled science that
everybody says there's.
Only one way you can think that that's a recipe
for a close mindedness that really prevents
innovation and prevents us from moving forward.
But if I were to say that there's geological
changes over long periods of time, about one
hundred thousand year cycles, these were called
the Milosevic cycles and that they have to
do with hot and cold.
And I'm not sure how much is sort of this
natural phenomenon based on the Earth's tilt
and how much is due to man.
They would say I'm a denier.
So it's it's not that Rand Paul is a denier
per say, although it sounds like he might
be.
It's that he's an ideologically biased libertarian
ophthalmologist who doesn't know about this
stuff and for political reasons, doesn't want
to accept what science has determined to be
the reality on this issue.
So what's very instructive for me about this
is that for some of us, compared to the wackiness
of Trump, a lot of these other Republicans
for the last four years start, you know, up
to a week ago, a lot of these Republicans
for the last four years seemed comparatively
less crazy than Donald Trump.
And it's probably true to some degree.
With Trump now gone, we are reminded of just
how wacky Rand Paul is and just how wacky
a lot of these other people are.
We knew it all along, but with Trump in comparison,
it was less obvious.
In some ways it's now very, very clear.